foreign
California hi Kelly welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you so much for having me
sure what's up
um okay so my husband is a guarantor on
his mom's mortgage
um it's not under his name uh Jessica
guarantor we did a Cash out refinance of
her house prior to her creating a living
trust for
um some Home Improvement projects with
the verbal expectation that she would
put the title in my husband's name upon
her passing however without me knowing
she threw in an additional Clause that
if we ever smell the house we would be
required to pay half of the profits to
his eldest son who is currently 20 years
old even though we have two additional
babies under two years old
um this Clause was thrown in after the
loan was approved we've already thrown a
hundred thousand dollars of our own
money cash into the house the house is
worth as of right now conservatively
1.25 million and the current loan
balance is a little under 400 000.
so my question is now that we are out of
um baby step two and mom and dad
answered
um mom
mom is unfortunately going through a lot
of Health situations and is she mentally
competent
yes she is okay your husband her son
needs to walk into her room with fresh
papers and have this fixed
she was in that was unethical
not fair and dumb
and she needs to fix it and she can do
that with a signature if your husband
will make his mother do that
okay
what happened to she doesn't
yeah we don't know what to do if I want
her to sign it to a way to a charity I
don't want anything else to do with it I
want it sold and given away to a charity
I do not want to wreck a 20 year old
irresponsible person's life because you
know what an irresponsible person with
four hundred thousand is really freaking
irresponsible
right dumb grandmother dumb dumb dumb
grandmother
right bad grandmother bad grandmother
bad bad bad bad bad bad do you have any
insight as to why she did this
um so she she wanted to make sure that
um her grandsons would be taken care of
when she's gone yeah it's an act of love
and she was dumb
that's why she did yeah
she has an improper view of what love
looks like yeah she needs to it's dumb
it's just you really your husband
allowed this I'm angry with him too
because his mother has told him what to
do way too many times he's way too grown
up for this
mommy said and then Mommy did and he
didn't say anything about it because
Mommy Mother Dearest nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope and you're mad at her and
you need to be mad at him
because he allowed it hey I'm kind of
mad at both of them yeah I don't blame
him it's easier to be mad at her because
she doesn't live in the house with you
but yeah but he's he's the one that
allowed this to go on and while he put
his name on the loan
I mean that's just unethical
on her part
and on his part very weak to allow this
to go down does she not trust your
husband
no she just had a fit of stupidity and
put it on paper I'm telling you it's not
I don't think it's deep stuff here
well I I think there is a little bit of
untrust um before we got married he was
very bad with money and since then we've
turned everything around with all the
baby stuff got out of the bus if giving
it to a 20 year old fixes that yeah what
are you gonna do yeah
there's a lot of control issues mom has
um
that's spoken like somebody who really
loves her husband but man you're more
mom than you are a wife
let's Saddle Up saddle up he needs to
March right in there and say Mom this
was wrong I went along with it I
shouldn't have and I'm not going along
with it so here's what's going to happen
you die I'm gonna sue the trust and ask
the judge to undo your stupidity if you
don't undo it with a signature right now
because giving a 20 year old four
hundred thousand dollars is absolutely
that's irresponsible with money is
absolutely asinine because it's going to
cause more problems than blessings
yeah okay it's not a blessing what does
a cocaine person what does a cocaine
addict do when they get more money more
cocaine
what's in irresponsible person do when
they get more money more irresponsible
what's a generous person do when they
get more money more generous money
magnifies our good and bad parts that
all of us have me included
and uh you know what does Dave get more
things with loud mufflers you know I
mean what you know the redneck I mean
you know what but I mean everybody's got
right that so so let's let's back it out
let's say Grandma did this perfectly and
there's only one kid is the right thing
to do is to put it in an in a trust yeah
that has yeah multiple multi-year
payouts on it yeah yeah and different
different triggering mechanisms that
indicate responsibility like you know if
he's going to college I would graduate
college if you're gonna go to college
you need to graduate college that's a
triggering event you need to uh be 25
and not be deeply in debt you know and a
triggering event you know and so some
level of maturity I'm not saying all 20
year olds are doofuses she said her 20
year old was irresponsible the mother
just said that okay so I'm that's what
I'm going off of so well he's been had a
ringside seat to his dad by the way I've
been a response when I was 20 you didn't
give me 400 Grand that would have been a
bad idea it would have been the worst
idea I've been a lot of loud mufflers
and beer involved yeah yeah it's just a
bad idea no I'm not saying that
everybody but but and there there we've
had 20 year olds on this show that were
more responsible and had their crap
together more than a lot of 60 year olds
so you can't can't it's not an age thing
but whatever you are good or bad is is
going to be magnified and when you're
gifting or doing inheritance you need to
structure it to ensure that you're being
a blessing and not magnifying stupidity
and let's go one step up the river here
a mother that would do this to her son
last minute dishonestly behind closed
doors without telling them has done this
crap for years she's a controller and if
you are married to somebody like this
you've got to speak up if you're married
to a coward who won't speak up against
his own mom or her own mom her own dad
or his own dad and say we as a family
are not getting into this deal and let
me tell you this is not a coward in the
sense of lack of Courage this is I don't
want to put up with the crap yes this is
going to unleash when I bother to have a
conflict with her because all conflicts
with her don't end well he just doesn't
want to screw with it I mean that's a
different kind of cowardice I don't
because I know it's you know when I walk
into the forest with the bear I'm gonna
meet a bear I mean he knows what he's
got he's dealt with it his whole life so
it's it's not cowardice like he's a
little wuss that's not the point he's
like it ain't worth a fight screw it
that's where he is but it is worth the
fight we spent a hundred thousand
dollars it was on money of your own
money and 400 go into an irresponsible
20 year old it's worth the fight it's
worth the fight it's worth calling her
out and oh by the way you signed the
note so that's what I mean doing
business you know at some point you got
to go it is worth the fight but this is
a this when we say coward we're not like
sniveling
yellow-bellied in the corner sucking
your thumb coward this is just I don't
want to deal with the pain in the butt
that is mom when you confront her but
the other side of that is it's your job
to protect your kid exactly and yourself
and your fan yeah so that's your job you
know so this whole thing comes at you
you go you know what I'm not signing
that note I'm not gonna do that we're
not gonna do that no it's not not an
option well you want to do the deal
we're doing it my way yeah we'll do it
my way or or not at all it's okay and I
also understand hey there's a million
dollar house we're gonna have this much
money
I'll start with losing my family over
not we're burning everything down I hold
that gum
and Dave you spoke with for with such
Insight that
it's almost as though you've seen this
before
30 years of doing this
yeah a couple times parents and
grandparents who try to bless their
their lineage and they bless you know
the worst one I ever had early on on
this show I took a call from a
grandfather who was sobbing and he was
he was uh 89 years old
and he had co-signed for a 30 000 pickup
for his grandson
and it got repoed
and they were coming after his farm
because he had no money but he had a
farm oh no and they were going to take
the 89 year old's farm for the
repossession on the pickup
and nobody in the family gave us crowd
stepping he thought he was helping his
grandson by co-signing and I'll never
forget that 89 year old crying on the
air